what's going on reject nation I'm Greg
Alva Donald yo-yo we gonna watch a video
that was requested by quite a bit of
people it's just another fun one
Avengers infinity war trailer Godzilla
king of the monsters style I love doing
these videos because there's so much to
review yes and them so much
afterwards commentary it make no these
are fun just for the reaction portion
and this comes from a channel called
Carpenter sound good for you man glad
this videos doing well hey I want to
give a patron the day shout out really
quick to a man named James Stegen James
Stegen lives all the way in a state that
is so boring I can never even remember
the name of it totally understandable
you understand but James you know what I
love about him because he comes from
such a boring state he cares about the
human race he cares about people and
anytime there is something going wrong
with California he's messaging me to
find out if we're okay just the other
day he messaged me saying hey heard
about those wildfires you guys near
those and I was like no idea what the
hell you're talking about
there are wild fires going on nothing
like oh damn on fire James I want to
thank you so much for always looking out
for us if I ever remember the state that
you live in I promise to keep tabs on
whatever is going on in there luan Ohio
maybe and if there's a tornado if
there's a fire you bet I will message
you as long as I remember where you're
from I'll keep a lookout because if
there's one guy who cares about the
worldwide news that's good I don't just
watch Stephen Colbert for Trump jokes
alright let's watch the this video
oh wow cease to exist there is
similarity keeping humanity go when we
won who knows that
[Music]
Louise done the only one with the will
to back on it
Wow the right cut blue that
[Music]
brother we can kill Klaus
[Music]
Wow man my nips are so hard right now in
the great trailer we need equipment
I
[Music]
[Music]
sweet that's rad
so I think that's gonna fall out style
for a civil war
oh that's cool I think we've seen a
video from this guy or there's a channel
that does similar types of videos where
they do in the end this style of and I
like these I mean he took the music from
the Godzilla trailer instead of taking
all the audio and putting it over the
Avengers characters trying to make them
you know match their mouths as to like
mine's a very for magazine or something
they just do the whole recut and to make
it in the style which is more contextual
recutting yeah let's have the narration
about the if he's saved a world ski you
know cuz like Vera Farmiga is I need to
like unleash these Titans of the world
because humanity's a virus yeah you got
a nose with a similar life yes directive
plan to save the world to have the
circling shots of the Avengers and the
similar to Millie Bobby Brown in the
beginning and then to have like the
cloud of Adonis appearing and then you
go into the narration of Thanos similar
to Vera Farmiga and then I liked how
there's a there's that shift in the
trailer where everything's blue and then
suddenly goes it's like the red orange
look yeah and it doesn't hear that
transitional shot well even you've got
that moment where there's the big like
surge up in the sky yeah that's a lot
like when Godzilla releases that you
know nuclear breath blast this guy what
I gotta say too in terms of just a
trailer for infinity war this is great
trailer we always heard the Russos
talking about how you know that US is
kind of like the main character in this
movie the trailers never made it feel
that way I'd always set up like he was
the villain then you walk out of that
movie you're like yes like the main
character that and then this trailer
advertises it like that like Danis is
the main character in this movie I love
that feeling of having a trailer
represent that very well like Betty to
make sure that represents that really
well is this one yes seriously one the
music goes along with the two because I
feel like the king of the monsters
whatever the music is they're using over
that trailer that got transplanted here
has a certain kind of triumphant tone to
it like this heavy and epic but it's not
quite as it as dark on the nose
as the original like a lot of the
infinity war bzb so that gives us one a
different Tambor and if it is a trailer
that does you know capitalize on the
Thanos being the lead it does kind of
give it that glorious Sheen that you
would want for a trailer like that yeah
yeah oh yeah I love this man this is a
fantastic well that at a trailer man
you're literally watching the next
generation of trailer cutters with these
yeah someone's gonna tap these people
pretty soon oh yeah this is this is
beautifully make carpenters sound
congratulations to you man this is a
fantastic video I'm glad this video is
performing so well right now go
subscribe to this guy's channel hey guys
you can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification about the
subscribe buttons are essentially broken
you can check us out on patreon because
every youtuber has a patreon now over
there we do full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is a music video
coverage so yeah it's a blasty blast
would love to have you become a patron
oject today yeah